and johnson love you today come out with
us let's talk about the book but i do
want to get pick your brain a little bit
about what we're seeing sort of
politically wise right now so he decided
to write this book and it's about a
minister going missing we've had some of
them on holiday recently no it's the
second thriller it's called one of our
ministers is missing is set in 2017 if i
wrote it now it'd be all of our
ministers are missing uh but it's not a
political book this is a thriller it's a
page turner and it follows on from my
first thriller uh late train to gypsy
hill so it's the same detective
detective superintendent mangan and for
good measure i'm writing a third one now
which will be out next year
with the same uh detective so it's a
trilogy
and it's such a relief to be out of
politics but no doubt you're going to
ask me something about that and your
career must have fed into into your
writing now i mean there must be the
aspects of what yeah so you know
as home secretary uh
i learned a lot about the background how
the police work with the security
services etc and there's some of that in
the book
but i really think i could have written
it had i not been home secretary you
know you can't give away any state
secrets i've signed the official secrets
act so
and anyway if you try to even touch upon
that you'd have to put the book through
the cabinet office it'd have to be
approved and all that so i've kept away
from all that
i hope
people who are have not got the
slightest interest in politics
will enjoy the book that's what i've
written it for i'm not out to win the
pulitzer prize i'm out to get people
turning the page and feeling that the
time they've spent with a 360 page book
there's been time well spent well
everyone likes a good page chad i'm sure
that they'll be picking up now let's
talk a little bit about the politics
that we're seeing right now where do i
even start i mean let's start with with
let's start with strikes because you're
a former post office worker we've seen
the posters are out again today 115 000
of them um they're calling for better
paying conditions the post office say
the royal mail want them to modernize i
mean where do you stand with where we're
seeing this strike actually i've seen
lots of modernization in in rome i was a
postman
for 19 years the the change since then
and you know keeping up with new
technology all of the introduced with
the union's
cooperation and they've seen numbers
fall as well there were two hundred
thousand post post men and women when i
was
leading the union that's down to about
115 000. so i don't understand that
they've also got an agreement that
monitors all of that and you know it's a
big groundbreaking agreement
so no the simple issue here is they're
being asked to take a pay cut and that
is replicated in loads of different
industries and we've had the longest
squeeze on wages since the napoleonic
wars which was a long time ago and now
those chickens are coming home to roost
you can't hold down people's pay as we
did going into the age of austerity that
was george osborne
and and and also see bonuses uh
eye-watering levels handed out
to chief executives the salary of chief
executives now is 110 times more than
the workers when i was a postman the
differential was about 30.
yeah i mean these people are not going
to put up with that those who are strong
who are lucky enough to be in a strong
trade union are going to fight back
and i hear people say i agree with free
trade unions and i agree with the right
to strike they just oppose every single
strike that comes along i support these
strikes and i think it's absolutely
crucial
that um
that a negotiated settlement is reached
that maintains the pay of postal workers
and rail workers and barristers
at the level it was originally to the
labour party could be doing more to get
behind the strikers that's not a labor
party argument i know some people
leaders
yeah the head of unite wants it to be a
label yeah but a head of unite always
finds a way to get a headline by
attacking the labor party you know
they've got enough to do with their
members you know attacking the labour
party is something they seem to do
on a weekly basis look that we are in a
in
unparalleled situation
we have a government that's missing in
action we have a government that i don't
mix with politicians now i mix with
people you know of all political
persuasions and it doesn't matter where
they come from
the incompetence they're seeing in this
government the fact that the prime
minister could
seek another eight weeks as prime
minister and then use it to go on
holiday in greece and to secure his
legacy people think now
that this party in government is not
putting the nation first they're putting
themselves first and it's going to be a
terrible terrible legacy uh one that
that boris johnson won't want i mean you
went on another holidays i don't you
mean but we'll discount that one
slovenia and you're kind of making my
point for me because that's what the
unions want they want to see a labour
party that gets fully behind them
because of this huge differential well
when you say fully behind them there's
this issue about
picket lines i mean 99 of
royal mail workers will go nowhere near
a picket line they still support the
strike they're on strike 99 of rail
workers won't go anywhere near a picket
line why has the picket line suddenly
become this kind of shrine if you
support us a dispute or not it's there
for a specific reason
and every labour leader since clermately
has said to their ministers don't go on
a picket line if you're part of a
political sect a far left sect it's fine
if you want to be the party of
government
yes of course you support workers you
support workers in a sense of trying to
get them into a negotiated settlement
but you don't stand against
commuters and you don't stand against
work people who are losing their postal
services you steer that middle course
and that's what kirsten is trying to do
he's trying to do but successfully
you finish the finish somewhat worse for
me you think it was you think a
successful middle class hey chris look
he was 27 points behind when he took
over from the disaster that preceded him
uh you know we're now anywhere between
eight and fifteen points ahead his
personal ratings are really good the
latest uh
ratings against liz truss or against
richie sooner
it looks like he's gonna be the loser
although i think he's the only grown up
in the room quite frankly but uh he
looks like he's going to be the loser
he's rating against them are really
really strong so you know i i
you know you are a broadcaster
for liz trust coming in she says she's
going to stand up
to putin she can't stand up to nick
robinson for half an hour but she's
going to stand up to putin i mean it's a
disaster i mean just for anyone doesn't
know that she pulled out an interview
with the bbc last night that's the point
you're referring to let me just stick a
little bit yeah with the labour party
now you said that sikhistan has managed
to take them ahead in the polls but as
you'll know they're still getting
hammered in scotland and to have a
majority any next relation they'd have
to take back scotland am i right
uh no they wouldn't have to but i think
that would be jolly helpful they got
hammered in scotland in 2015
less hammered now i mean the snp have
kind of stolen uh closed very
successfully nicholas sturgeon is a very
successful and very astute politician by
the way would you like to see there
being an agreement between some of those
parties that call themselves progress to
the labor party the lib dems and the smp
i don't think i want to see an agreement
no i think you know the electorate
are wise enough and sensible enough to
make up their own minds as we saw in
recent by-elections
they will use this lousy voting system
we have
uh first pass to post to their advantage
uh and i'm pretty sure they'll do that
at general election it doesn't need any
pacs or agreements
in fact that would be counterproductive
in in our under our current political
system but uh but i think people will be
absolutely determined after the shambles
we've seen not just over the last year
over the last 12 years
you know through austerity through the
uh you know all the other tensions that
we've seen
crime rising crime had halved under
labour by the way it's now
up at
the highest level for 20 years
people are going to make their own
decisions on where they vote to get this
terrible government out if if it's a
terrible government i mean they may
recover i can't see it i mean you were
in government at the time when uh the
financial crisis here and gordon brown
um pulled all those levers i mean
something like that is going to have to
happen again a very important point
kamali because because you're i was
there in 2008 when
alistair darling was told by the second
biggest bank in the world if you don't
do something quickly people are going to
lose their mortgages you know when
alistair asked to define what you mean
soon they meant three hours we had three
hours car scrappage scheme
temporary uh reduction in v80 to get
people shopping again the future job
scheme all of those things were done it
was a plan and it was implemented
there's no plan at the moment as far as
we understand there's not even a sketchy
outline of a plan they're waiting for
the new prime minister um which i failed
to understand the prime minister's the
first amongst equals the prime minister
is still there they could be doing stuff
now but you're right it's going to take
a package on that kind of level
to deal with the crisis we're facing but
the labour plan would see 28 billion
spent for six months this isn't going to
be over in six months so you can spend
another 28 billion and then where does
that money come from is that what is it
borrowing maybe
so when we were faced with people losing
their mortgages and of course
we bailed out the banks what was the
alternative of course we did uh and you
you take these things a step at a time i
think the lacuna to use a word that's
only ever used in politics or the law uh
you know the gap
in labor's thinking is about small
businesses there's no price cap for them
and they are going to the wall
and labor needs to plug that gap as well
and yes do it in six monthly stages
inflation's going to come down i don't
think that's going to make much of a
difference to the price of energy but
inflation is going to come down two more
questions for there you go mr johnson
and one
former has a home secretary shimai ma
began there's some stories about her in
the papers today i don't know if you've
seen it yeah the canadian uh yeah
exactly about secret services taking
hurt us here i mean your reflections on
that and if that is true just astounding
that they would have been responsible
my reflection i know a lot of things
about the secret services which uh you
know i must never
divulge would it surprise me that the
secret services were involved in
finding uh radicals and
tracking radicals no i'm not sure what
the background is nobody knows what the
background to this is
but it doesn't surprise me
at all uh an involvement there something
that services do all kinds of things to
keep us safe they're not surprised by
the involvement of an ally in moving on
i am i'm surprised i'm surprised yes but
my presumption is that
uk services would have known about we
have a very closer it's called the five
eyes
close relationship with canada and
australia and america and new zealand
and i think it would be incomprehensible
that our
security service didn't know
uh finally then i thought on uh mikhail
gorbachev who passed away last night
obviously by the time you're in office
it was a very different russia that
you're dealing with not no longer the
soviet union but his legacy now as we
see what's happening in ukraine just
reflect a little bit on michael
gorbachev in his life well he was one of
these uh astounding people who take
huge risks for what they see
as the greater good
he was putting his country and
piece of the world first
he never stopped being a communist by
the way but he saw that
that the way russia was going that this
uh
this kind of totalitarian state couldn't
survive in the 20th century never mind
the 21st century
and he took such a risk i think david
trimble who died a few weeks ago equally
to stand up against the people you've
been with for many years and to argue
that what we've been doing is wrong
takes enormous courage i'm not sure i'd
have it and i'd have that courage and i
don't think many politicians have
miguel gorbachev did and he's uh
he's rightly being
being lauded now and it's uh it's a sad
loss although he lived to a good age
yeah he did and uh lorded by us but i'll
tell our viewers in a moment not so much
in russia alan johnson really love to
speak to you this morning thank you very
much
for being with us